bench for Bruce Brown
at a mile
Christian Brown left him jokic gets
there
and he held on the rim of the ball is
above the cylinder so offensive
interference
that was a well executed play
causing confusion
in the right call
and they're looking at The Rim right now
saying it's a little crooked
does look crooked from our angle here it
looks a little crooked
[Applause]
all the players are checking it out now
some guys don't need to look
jokic's trying to fix it himself
looks good now it looks better
make sure it's level
[Applause]
there's Scott Foster in his 24th NBA
Finals game his 29th year in the league
[Music]
so they want to make sure that it's
leveled
I have somebody to have to come out and
check it out
just saying it's fine all right so you
watch at a mile obviously hangs on the
rim off a basket interference offensive
interference but it looks like there
from this angle that it goes right back
to where it was
it's fine let's play
you would say that anyway
so they got the ladder
now this is beforehand
holyokeish he doesn't want to stop I'll
fix it
brings it down it looks like it pops
right back up
am I nitpicking that I don't want a guy
in a suit and tie doing that job
well they've got five assistants
rummaging through their toolbox
of two different ladders and they're
trying to they got a lot of cameras to
work through
what happened to just a straight level
like you used to when you built a fence
right right
now clearly they feel it's it's just off
a little bit
the naked eye it looks fine
foreign
so what kind of like what does this do
is there anything you can do because
nothing you could do as a coach to keep
people warmed up but
it gives guys like Murray and jokic who
are playing for the whole half
it gives them extra rest as it gives
Butler not a bio
well apparently they've got it fixed
because the ladders are going away
and I think we'll play again thankfully
good job the man in the suit came
through right he did what the worry is
if the game didn't go on we had all this
time what he might say that's why I
think they sped up the pain saving us
our jobs
random predictions gone awry well done
suit man
all right Larry Hall excellent job you
know and that's not his only
responsibility leveling the basket I
mean he's got multiple responsibilities
I'm sure